la chanteuse est résistante joséphine
baker va faire son entrée cet après midi
au panthéon à paris et regardez cette
image de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
aux etats-unis cette mère nommage n'a
été rendu à new york l' empire state
building s'est illuminée aux couleurs de
la france bleu blanc rouge l'artiste qui
est devenue française étaient nos états
unis avant de fuir la ségrégation
adaptant les paroles de votre plus grand
succès
vos claviers
mon pays c'est paris
chacun de nous ce soir
murmures ce refrain
sonnant comme un hymne à l'amour
ma france
c'est joséphine en chansons avec les
honneurs militaires et comme décor paris
voilà résumée en quelques symboles la
vie et l'oeuvre de joséphine baker
[Musique]
dans ce cercueil symbolique ni corps ni
cendres mais quatre poignées de terre
prélevés dans des lieux chers à
l'artiste saint-louis sa ville natale la
dordogne où elle réside à de longues
années monaco ou à l'est et elle restera
enterré et paris
à
[Musique]
désormais la poupée iconique de 29 cm et
2 205 g a laissé la place à 6 tailles de
corps différents dans leur dernière
gamme pas moins de 170 combinaisons
différentes de teintes de peau de
corpulence ou de couleur de cheveux et
ça marche l'an dernier la marque a
dépassé le milliard de dollars de
chiffre d'affaires est le modèle le plus
vendu c'est celui ci une poupée afro aux
formes généreuses mechia compatriote une
lettre lue dans une bibliothèque face à
un micro vintage eric zemmour joue le
parallèle avec l'appel du 18 juin du
général de gaulle pour annoncer après
des mois de faux suspense ce que tout le
monde ça va j'ai décidé de me présenter
à l'élection présidentielle
moins de dix minutes et c'est une vidéo
dans laquelle eric zemmour déroule son
analyse toujours la même d'une france en
déclin à cause du poids de l'immigration
et m me présente
[Musique]
tellement des milliers c'est la croix
haute et ne pas s'étaler notre monsieur
eric zemmour s'est officiellement
déclaré candidat pour l'élection
présidentielle ce mardi et sans gros
sabots ça y est il y va pour délivrer la
france de l'invasion homosexuels aux
musulmanes et délivrer l'hexagone des
vols chez bic décadente qui gangrène nos
organes d'information et veulent
transformer nos dires et le gaillard en
val femmes exception faite de notre béni
canal numéro 16 quand je suis rentré
dans le métier les rails c'était des
voyous
c'était des rebelles c'est aider voilà
il était toujours à jour d'hui cd
sermoner et des prêcheurs et des
donneurs de leçons et seul écrivain je
trouve que c'est pas notre métier de
donner de telles son nom n'est pas et
sait pas s'il me semble qu il me semble
que c'est pas ça bien sûr on vous a
méprisé
les puissants les élites les bien
pensants les journées là larbitre ça
c'est vraiment toi oui alors la première
réaction a été la surprise un déjà la
deuxième réaction a été élevé moore fait
ce qu'il dit le bien pensant et puis
bien profond je suis très content de te
voir on aimerait que journaliste et
écrivain vous êtes présent à votre insu
dans le clip d'eric zemmour ce qu'il a
il a il a émis un clip alors il aime
tout le monde mais moi j'étais un petit
peu déçu de pas y être le véritable
amour c'était genre côté pas dans le
club d'eric zemmour franchement trs min
vous n'avez pas déménager et pourtant
vous avez la sensation de ne plus être
chez vous vous n'avez pas quitté votre
pays mais c'est comme si votre pays vous
avez quittez sur la forme la vidéo en
prod quantité d'image de films de
reportages pour certaines a priori non
négociée par l'équipe zemmour avec leurs
propriétaires
notre service des images a estimé le vol
à près de cent mille euros d'archivés
sans compter les télés sim les
reportages ou encore les drones et on
pense n'ont pas été filmée par les
équipes de zemmour cent mille euros
c'est s'ils l'avaient demandé les droits
car maintenant il va falloir rajouter
les procès haddaoui
et l'argent que nous recevrons des
zemmour sera bien évidemment reversés à
des associations d aide aux migrants et
aux amours bonne campagne il y avait des
images mais également de la musique pour
habiller cette annonce la septième
symphonie de beethoven morceaux déjà
utilisée dans le passé au cinéma
notamment dans le discours d'un roi
irréversible ou encore ça ne s'invente
pas dans cet autre film
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la beauté ou
anita mallet vous sur sambre super sayen
golden prise à 2 3
voilà
bloqué trois nuits dans un pub à cause
de la neige
c'est la mésaventure arrivée à une
soixantaine de clients d'un
établissement du nord de l'angleterre
vendredi soir ils assistent à un concert
d'un groupe de reprises d'oasis dehors
une tempête de neige s'abat sur la
région et rend les routes impraticables
pendant tout le week end ils sont restés
confinés dans le bar heureusement il y
avait à boire et à manger aucune
inquiétude parmi les convives
l'équipe de l'auberge a tout organisé
pour passer le temps
on a fait du karaoké des quiz des jeux
de cartes et de société
les gens ont aidé à nettoyer les tables
tout le monde à aider c'était super
laurent citez moi une mauvaise habitude
à table un sachant crottés au numéro 3
je dirais la chaîne caisse
voter et numéro 3
je vais annuler le dîner de vendredi moi
je pourrais pas être à ce qu'on avait
prévu que je passe à la maison mais on
avait l'air bien en forme juste pour moi
c'est une première de manger ce type
d'entrée j'ai pas forcément les ai
mangés le chou n'a pas goûté jettent un
doute et josy franchement je commence à
faire une nouvelle génération
c'est chic ça les filles bravo on
l'appelle le légume trempette oui
on n'avait pas eu vent de cette
information
chaque jour on fera une petite chanson
de noël et là on a trouvé alors faut que
vous reconnaissiez quichotte vive le
vent est celui qui trouve en premier
hagan gagne
j'ai le droit de donner mon avis